joe biden tony blinken le secrétaire
d'état mettre l'emphase sur le fait
qu'ils pensent qu'une action militaire
russe envers l'ukraine est probable est
qu'il faut absolument se préparer à ce
risque leur ton est vraiment un temps
l'heure est grave joe biden a dit par
exemple que ce serait la plus grave
incursion militaire en europe depuis la
seconde guerre mondiale c'est le genre
de langage qui est employé par les
américains alors que le président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky dans un
message vidéo enregistré hier un message
au peuple ukrainien disait il ne faut
surtout pas paniquer on vit en guerre
depuis 2014 le risque est toujours été
là le risque est toujours là mais n'est
pas forcément plus élevés qu'ils
n'étaient auparavant je pense que
volodymyr zelensky se soucie des effets
sur l'économie ukrainienne de tout cet
du fait que les médias parlent sans
cesse de la possibilité d'une incursion
russe d'une grande guerre évidemment
cela décourage les investisseurs et
c'est quelque chose qui se fait sentir
notamment sur le taux de change de la
monnaie nationale la hryvnia